die tagesordnungspunkte 11 bis 11 clp
und 11g bis 11 die sowie die
zusatzpunkte drei bis fünf beratung von
vorlagen zur ökologisch sozialen
transformationen in der handelspolitik
und zu nachhaltigem wachstum und
wohlstand sowie zur tarifbindung
die hat noch lieber wochen
so liebe kollegen kollegen der
platzwechsel ist in jeder hinsicht
vollzogen ich eröffne die aussprache
bitte auch die vertreter aller
regierungsbank war herr seehofer
vielleicht die gespräche nach draußen zu
verlegen
april jedoch ulrich schwarz der
öffentlichkeit teilen als erste rednerin
der kollegin anja hajduk für ihre wurde
die letzte rede vor dem deutschen
bundestag das wort danke herr präsident
sehr geehrte damen und herren die korona
pandemie hat unser land verändert sie
hat prioritäten in der gesellschaft
verschoben und hat bestehende schieflage
noch sichtbarer gemacht corona brachte
einschränkungen und einschnitte die wir
uns gar nicht vorstellen konnten aber
mit der nun beginnenden wirtschaftlichen
erholung ergeben sich chancen die
notwendige ökologische und soziale
transformation voranzutreiben indem
verständnis den weg aus der krise als
chance zu nutzen gilt es also die
enormen ausgaben programme die wir hier
vor sehen wirklich zur wirtschaftlichen
stabilisierung jetzt aber auch
einzusetzen und zu verknüpfen mit dem
klimaverträglichen umbau unserer
wirtschaft
die programme der
regierung sind dafür nicht ausreichend
sie sind lückenhaft
der ausbau der erneuerbaren energien ist
immer noch unzureichend schritte zu
einer kreislaufwirtschaft sehen wir in
dem sehen sie in ihren programmen gar
nicht vor und das thema biodiversität
geht auch unter und dabei ist es doch
eigentlich schon fast eine
binsenweisheit dass der globale
wettbewerb um die technologien von
morgen in vollem gange ist
neben der eu haben viele wirtschaftlich
starke länder angekündigt bis 2050 co2
neutral werden zu wollen
also das frühzeitige einschwenken auf
den pariser klimaschutz fahrt ist doch
offenkundig die große chance im
internationalen wettbewerb zu bestehen
zu bestehen um die modernsten
technologien in der grundstoffindustrie
in der automobilbranche im maschinenbau
oder auch in der bauwirtschaft dieses
umsteuern dass davon sind wir überzeugt
sichert den wohlstand von morgen und
sichert natürlich auch eine gesunde
umwelt
wir grünen legen heute einen antrag mit
zehn punkten vor der hier für die
politischen rahmen und weichenstellungen
setzt weil die braucht es natürlich
gehört dazu ein co2 preis ein wirksamer
co2 preis dafür muss der europäische
emissionshandel von
emissionszertifikaten mit von mit ms
entschuldigung darf muss der europäische
emissionshandel mit einer deutlichen
reduzierung von vorhandenen
aktions zertifikaten reformiert werden
und überschüssigen zertifikate müssen
gelöscht werden
natürlich gehören in der zukunft auch
klima verträge mit dazu klima verträge
mit unternehmen um ihnen
investitionssicherheit zu geben diese
verträge sollen die differenz erstatten
zwischen dem aktuellen co2 preis und den
tatsächlichen co2 vermeidungskosten
welche durch investitionen in neue
verfahren ausgelöst werden das sind nur
zwei aber herrn zentrale bausteine die
wir brauchen
wir grünen sind überzeugt man muss so
einen punkte programm einbetten in ein
großes investitions und
transformationsprogramm für die gesamte
dekade die vor uns liegt
annalena baerbock hat nicht umsonst
heute morgen noch einmal darauf
hingewiesen und erinnert dass die usa
unter ihrem präsident joe biden sich mit
einem gewaltigen investitionsprogramm
1,9 billionen dollar schwer
auf den weg machen und europa und
deutschland darf da nicht zurückfallen
und deswegen möchte ich noch folgendes
sagen die kanzlerin hat heute morgen in
ihrer rede zum europäischen rat gesagt
auf eine außergewöhnliche krise hätte
die europäische union mit dem
wiederaufbau von eine außergewöhnliche
antwort gefunden
vielleicht ist es außergewöhnlich dass
die eu tatsächlich eine antwort gefunden
hat aber ich möchte sagen es sollte
gewöhnlich sein und nicht
außergewöhnlich sein dass wir dauerhaft
kraftvoll in unsere zukunft investieren
und wenn wir in die zukunft
tieren und dafür auch einen kredit
aufnehmen dann ist das nicht
unvernünftig sondern ökonomische
normalität und rationalität und deswegen
wünsche ich mir für europa dass diese
investitionsinitiative verstetigt werden
ich wünsche mir vom deutschen bundestag
dass er regeln schafft dass er eine
investitions regel schafft die zukünftig
ein solches starkes investitionsprogramm
auch in deutschland ermöglicht und ich
darf mir das ja wünschen weil ich dem
deutschen bundestag nicht mehr angehören
werde und bedanke mich für die
zusammenarbeit
[Applaus]
ob wir den eindruck sie jahren im
deutschen bundestag insgesamt vier
legislaturperioden angehört und
wesentlich dazu beigetragen die
parlamentarische demokratie
fortzuentwickeln insbesondere in ihrer
segensreichen arbeit als stellvertreter
funktion des haushaltsausschuss ist in
den anfangsjahren ihrer karriere im
deutschen bundestag habe ich ganz
herzlich im namen des präsidiums und
wahrscheinlich gesamten hauses für ihre
tätigkeit bedanken für die zeit nach dem
deutschen bundestag
das kann das können sich viele wir uns
ja gar nicht vorstellen dafür sei nach
den deutschen bundestag alles gute
wünschen
nächster redner
ist der kollege andreas lämmel cdu csu
fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren den wohlstand von morgen
sichern
das ist glaube ich die wichtigste
aufgabe die auch den nächsten jahren vor
uns liegt ganz ohne zweifel
denn und deswegen ist die diskussion die
wir heute vielleicht beginnt sehr gut
aber der nächste deutsche bundestag wird
diese dass diese diskussion sicherlich
sehr viel intensiver führen muss wir
sind noch beschäftigt damit die folgen
der korona pandemie zu bekämpfen die
umfangreichen staatlichen programme
laufen noch aber der blick in die
zukunft darf deswegen nicht abhanden
kommen
wir müssen aber auch wahrscheinlich zwei
schritte schneller gehen in zukunft um
im prinzip wettbewerbsfähig bleibt zu
bleiben im vergleich mit amerika oder im
vergleich mit den amerikanischen staaten
die bewachung der wettbewerbsfähigkeit
deutschlands wird letztendlich auch
darüber entscheiden ob die sozialen
sicherungssysteme die wir in deutschland
haben auch in zukunft noch finanzierbar
bleiben
ich frage mich natürlich warum die
grünen jetzt so einen umfangreichen
antrag zum ende der legislaturperiode
vorlegen denn im prinzip wer hat das ja
am anfang der nächsten eigentlich viel
besser gewesen
aber meine damen und herren die cdu und
die cdu csu hatte diese woche hat die
dieser woche ihr regierungsprogramm
vogel ist erwarten sie
was sein sondern leise dann wissen sie
wir machen keine anträge wir legen ein
regierungsprogramm vor und wenn sie doch
mal einen blick reinwerfen das
regierungsprogramm der union da sind
genau diese zukunftsfragen ganz klar
wieder gelegt und ganz klar formuliert
meine damen und herren
und wir sind überzeugt und wir sind
überzeugt als die einzige partei hier im
deutschen bundestag dass deutschland ein
industriestandort ein starker
industriestandort bleiben muss und dafür
werden wir alles tun
meine damen und herren aber überwunden
bürokratie hohe strompreise find sie die
gesetze die sie ja als grüne noch
vollstrecken wollten und da
nachholbedarf bei der infrastruktur
das ist das was im moment die wirtschaft
bei der entwicklung hemmt viele von
ihnen kennen der die bilder von gulliver
das war heute schon mal kurz auch schon
erwähnt wurden die wirtschaft liegt
gefesselt am boden rote und grüne
winzlinge versuchen mit immer mehr
schnüren sozusagen die wirtschaft
handlungsunfähig zu machen und deswegen
heißt unsere
deswegen heißt unsere regierungsprogramm
ein entfesselungskünstler dabei
und deswegen brauchen wir keine grünen
und rote weitere schnüren wir brauchen
freiraum für die wirtschaft wir brauchen
freiraum für unternehmer damit sie es
sozusagen das tun können was ihre
aufgabe ist und man bundes sicher
manchmal spitzenkandidat wada hat olaf
scholz spd spitzenkandidat bei der
beiden trat der deutschen wirtschaft
diese woche gesagt also wenn er gewählt
wird dann werden die strompreise für die
industrie drastisch sinken soll
das hätte können das hätte können und
jetzt schon mal da sind doch leere
versprechungen heute nachmittag werden
wir das klimaschutzgesetz und weitere
gesetze energiewirtschaftsgesetz eine
erneuerbare energien verordnung
verabschieden
olaf scholz ist derjenige der persönlich
verhindert hat dass es eine
übergangsregelung gibt bald beim
spitzenausgleich für die
energieintensive industrie punkt 1 das
ist eine belastung der wirtschaft und
eine starke belastung der wirtschaft
die regierung hat eine kapelle ordnung
vorgelegt die völlig unzureichend
wir als union haben versucht diese diese
kappen liegend verordnung so weit auf
die person damit diese belastungen aus
dem co2 handel für die wirtschaft auch
traktor werden wer war der verhinderung
die sozialdemokraten meine damen und
herren und das fallen doch handeln und
reden völlig auseinander
das zweite beispiel als dem
grünen-antrag da schreiben sie da
schreiben sie deshalb müssen
planungsprozesse beschleunigt und das
planungsrecht entbürokratisiert werden
da habe ich dann nach anzeige klickt
bitte daher wird daran da erheblich mehr
daran als wir das
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz für die
verkehrswege warten wollten
bis jetzt planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
für die für die strom versicherung
leitungsbau so energiewende wir hatten
das alles verhindern
die grünen bis in den bundesrat hinein
haben sie alle vereinbarungen diesen
gesetzen verhindert seine damen und
herren und jetzt schreibt wie sie solche
sätze in das programm also das kann man
sich ja nur fragen dann war doch was
ganz mag ich es da steht in ihrem antrag
eine handelspolitik die sich dem
planetaren grenzen
an den plattengrenzen wollen sie jetzt
mit den massen menschen den
handelsproblemen treten oder was heißt
das also wenn sie solche anträge
schreiben sollten sie die so schreibt
dass der mensch das auch verstehen meine
damen und herren max weber hat mal
geschrieben politik bedeutet ein starkes
langsames bohren von harten brettern mit
leidenschaft und augenmaß zugleich das
war das leitmotiv meiner arbeit hier im
deutschen bundestag
manche dieser harten bretter sind so
hart gewesen die sie nicht so gut
geworden aber im wesentlichen sind diese
blätter doch ganz gut geglückt in den
letzten jahren leidenschaftlich haben
wir viele dinge diskutiert wir haben es
abgestritten wir haben aber immer uns
fair glaube ich auseinandergesetzt
nun endet nach 16 jahren meine tätigkeit
hier im deutschen bundestag
und ich bleibe der politik trotzdem treu
es waren für mich wirklich interessante
jahren muss ich sagen es war eine
erfolgreiche jahre
es waren jahre
in dem ich immer wieder neues gelernt
habe und es waren jahre in denen wir
erfolge feiern können aber auch sehr
viele niederlagen einstecken muss das
ist leider so und wenn ich manchmal auf
die nerven gegangen mit mit
ordnungspolitik oder vielleicht mit
meinen bedenken gegen die einschränkung
von bürgerrechten während der pandemie
dann kommt das daher meine damen und
herren das ich vor über 30 jahren erlebt
habe wie ein land und so geht's sand
seiner wirtschaft und damals bin ich mit
auf die straße gegangen wir haben
gekämpft für freiheit für demokratie und
für soziale marktwirtschaft und diese
begriffe sind für mich keine hohlen
phrasen das ist bei der innere
überzeugung und dafür werde ich auch
weiterhin kämpfen bedanke mich bei allen
die ich gekleidet haben über die vielen
jahre
ich werde auch allen mit denen ich mich
gestritten habe die werde trotzdem auf
der straße noch grüßen also brauchen sie
keine angst haben also herzlichen dank
gilt auch und alles gute für diejenigen
die gewählt werden und ich hoffe dann
dass die unions fraktion nach der
deutsche bund nach der wahl zum
deutschen bundestag doppelt so groß ist
als halter also
herr kollegen auch ihnen auch ihnen gilt
der dank des hauses für 16 jahre
parlamentarischer tätigkeit der laufen
sie mir die anmerkung ich wünsche ihnen
tatsächlich für die zeit nach dem
bundestag alles gute aber als
vorsitzender bau und raum kommission
habe ich gerade schweißperlen auf die
stirn begonnen in alle fraktionen
doppelt so groß werden wie sie gegenteil
die sind dann haben wir probleme mit der
unterbringung aber das ist dann nicht
mehr ihr problem vielen dank für ihre
tätigkeit nicht starten ist der kollege
leif erik reumann fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
liebe bürger herr präsident meine damen
und herren zunächst noch von mir
herzlichen grüße an sie herr level
vielen dank für die immer gute
zusammenarbeit im wirtschaftsausschuss
und alles gute
ja die platanen grenzen die waren wir
auch aufgefallen dazu gab es im antrag
auf viele sternchen ich weiß nicht ob es
am sender gaga lag oder ob sich die
anlage voll waren beim schreiben
die frage wird sich vielleicht später
erklären den wohlstand von morgen wollen
wir sicher natürlich das wollen wir alle
so steht es auch über ihrem antrag es
hört sich gut an aber so wird es ganz
sicher nichts ihre öko sozialistische
transformation bringt uns eher wieder
richtung steinzeit und das wollen wir
verhindern
ihre kanzlerkandidat in bernburg meinte
ja vorhin klimagerechte wohlstand wäre
der soziale kitt für europa nur soziales
daran wirklich gar nichts
es ist eher so dass wir vielleicht wenn
sie so weitermachten bald den kind den
kitt aus den fenstern zur ernährung
nutzen müssen so geht s nicht alle
theoretischen programme kosten nämlich
unheimlich viel geld dass alle bürger
werden aufbringen müssen und dieses
programm hier soll ja auch schon wieder
ein
halbe billion kosten wir sind ja schon
bei gesamtkosten daumen leopoldina für
die energiewende von 7,5 millionen euro
also der steuerzahler nach weiter
zittern ebenso der autofahrer die 16
cent mehr pro liter sprit dürften nur
der anfang sein
die ex- und import wirtschaft wird
einführung von co2 zölle neue
schwierigkeiten bekommen aber die beste
idee ist ja dass sie den strompreis über
die massiven ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien senken wollen
ja das wird mit dem börsenstrompreis
funktionieren wenn das angebot stark
genug ist wind weht sonne scheint und so
weiter aber genau das bedeutet bedeutet
eben auch mehr subventionen für die
betreiber der anlagen und diese
subventionen wer bezahlt die am ende wir
alle also bitte vergessen sie nicht
unsere bürger die ard steht für eine
echte entlastung der stromkunden und die
braucht es wirklich dringend denn hier
sind wir mittlerweile schon
europameister ob sie auf dem
fußballplatz was wird naja nach dem
spiel gestern habe ich so meine zweifel
aber wir hoffen ja noch und die
strompreise steigen weiter deswegen wird
das ganze ja jetzt von der
bundesregierung über die senkung der
eeg-umlage verschleiert das ist der alte
trick linke tasche rechte tasche dann
zeit eben jetzt zum großteil der
steuerzahler also auch hier werden die
bürger wieder hinter die fichte geführt
diese politik ist nicht nur unsinnig sie
es auch unredlich
wir müssen dringend winter mit den
strompreis und deshalb fordern wir als
afd in unserem antrag die senkung der
stromsteuer auf das minimum
denn damit könnten wir die verbraucher
direkt um fast sieben milliarden euro
entlasten
das wäre eine echte soziale im ausland
die grünen behaupten ja klimaschutz
funktioniere nur sozial
ich kann aber wiederholung soziales
daran wirklich nicht entdecken im
gegenteil sie haben ja mit rot-grün
dieses teure und vermurkste projekt erst
auf den weg gemacht
steigen und steigen also erzählt sie es
bitte nichts von sozialen und jetzt
wollen sie in die regierung um uns alle
ihre verbote unterzuschieben du sollst
nicht fliegen du sollst kein verbrenner
autofahren du sollst kein fleisch essen
du sollst kein eigenheim haben und und
und ihr öko sozialistischen pläne die
nun um erzogenen menschen von beziehern
die machen mir persönlich angst und ich
bin wieder level in der ddr groß
geworden wo die sed herrschaften wir
wissen besser was gut für dich ist und
das haben sie für 17 millionen menschen
bewusst erstaunlicherweise aber so sah
das land am ende auch aus und das möchte
ich bitteschön nicht noch einmal in
meinem vaterland erleben ihre ganze
klima alarm ist so voller widersprüche
die sie einfach auch nicht auflösen
können
es ist denn wirklich kurz vor zwölf beim
klima fragezeichen wenn es denn wirklich
so wäre dann gäbe es ja nur eine
schnelle lösung dafür den co2 ausstoß zu
senken
das sind die nahezu emissionsfreien
kernkraftwerke aber die wollen sie
wiederum nicht und was machen sie ihren
eigentlich das haben sie mir erklären
können was machen sie denn eigentlich
wenn kein wind weht und keine sonne
scheint da kommt auch aus ihrer
steckdose immer noch strom dem nicht aus
kernkraftwerken in frankreich oder
tschechien oder irgendwo anders hier aus
europa schalten sie dann alle freiwillig
ihre verbraucher haben oder melden sie
in strom einfach ab was machen sie denn
dann
da müssten sie ja schon irgendwie mal
selber in vorleistung gehen ansonsten
ist das wirklich eine scheinheilig
die durch nicht zu überbieten ist ihre
kanzlerkandidatin hatte vorhin gesagt
china sei weltmeister bei erneuerbaren
energien und tatsächlich diese
information von fromberg stimmt sogar
ist ja bei ihr auch nicht immer der fall
aber das gehört eben zu weit auch dazu
china plant und baut 31 neue
kernkraftwerke weil die eben beständig
günstigen strom produzieren und nahezu
emissionsfrei sind auch in europa auch
in europa entstehen neue reaktoren also
der ausstieg deutschlands ist ein
sonderweg wir haben das land mit den
sichersten kernkraftwerken wir sorgen
auf der ganzen welt übrigens auch beim
weltklimarat noch für kopfschütteln
wir gehen hier einen sinnlosen sonderweg
der auch in der klimadebatte überhaupt
nichts beiträgt
dieses land ist irgendwie politisch aus
den fugen geraten und es wird immer
dramatischer werden wenn die grünen auch
noch in die regierung kommen
allerdings ist diese utopie schon viel
viel weiter verbreitet
auch in den anderen parteien leider und
das scheint mir das kernproblem zu sein
die grünen sind halt die grünen okay
aber alle anderen dackeln dem
ideologischen irrsinn der grünen
mittlerweile hinterher
auch unions-fraktionschef brinkhaus
kündigte an mittlerweile an dass das
autofahren richtig teuer werden 15,5
cent mehr pro liter benzin will die
union auch was unterscheidet sie jetzt
eigentlich noch von den grünen ich kann
da wirklich nichts mehr erkennen es gibt
wirklich keinen unterschied mehr ihre
partei ist nach 16 jahren merkel völlig
entkernt und ein ende ist nicht
abzusehen
eines möchte ich ihnen der union
deswegen noch mit auf den weg geben in
die nächste legislaturperiode
wer mit der grünen verbots partei
regieren will
wird selber zur perrons partei wer mit
den öko sozialisten gemeinsame sachen
machen will der holt sich eben auch den
sozialismus wieder ins land und wer mit
denen regieren will die darüber
diskutieren das wort deutschland aus
ihrem programm zu streichen der wirt
selbst zum deutschland abschaffen und
deswegen geht nur der blaue wählt
verhindert grün
herzlichen dank vielen dank herr kollege
bernd westphal spd tritt sehr geehrter
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir wollen bei allem respekt das war wie
gewohnt eine nach hinten gewandte rede
versuchen wir es mal mit der zukunft der
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland ist
trotzdem bande mit krisen und
auswirkungen einer der erfolgreichsten
wirtschaftsstandorte im internationalen
vergleich
und wenn man sich mal die parameter
anguckt lebt das vor allen dingen daran
dass wir gerade in der krise einen
handlungsfähigen staat hatten
der mit vielen konjunkturprogramm mit
wirtschaftshilfen aber auch mit
kurzarbeitergeld diese wirtschaft die
betriebe stabilisiert hat und es war vor
allem das kurzarbeitergeld was auf den
weg gebracht worden ist was
beschäftigung gesichert hat in den
unternehmen was die anderen
rahmenbedingungen angeht kommt es
sicherlich darauf an qualifizierte
arbeitnehmer zu haben
unser bildungssystem aber auch eine
intakte infrastruktur spielt eine rolle
genauso wie wissenschaft und forschung
forschungs und entwicklungsausgaben aber
auch ein rechtsstaat der verlässlichkeit
und planungssicherheit die fahrt aber
auch hohe soziale und umweltstandards
dieses innovative umfeld diese
stabilität sind rahmenbedingungen für
investitionen sind vor allen dingen
möglichkeit
dass es wird gute arbeit mit
mitbestimmung arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer mit ihrer kompetenz sind
mit ihren qualifikationen die sich dort
einbringen und es sind auch
tarifverträge die für diese stabilität
sorgen wenn man sich das mal anguckt in
anderen ländern wird die das
organisieren
bei uns gibt es konflikte in den
unternehmen mit sozialpartnern die durch
mitbestimmung durch betriebsräte durch
aufsichtsräte gute organisationen haben
das zu lösen in anderen ländern streitet
man sich mit vier gerichtsverfahren vor
gericht darum was fortschritt er
verhindert wir haben große
herausforderungen eine davon ist
sicherlich dekarbonisierung wir haben ja
heute noch die debatte heute nachmittag
groß und klimaschutz und um den ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien geht das sehen
wir als sozialdemokraten auch wir werden
sicherlich was den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien angeht mehr
fortschritte erzielen müssen
und das fängt schon an mit einer
innovativen stahlindustrie die überhaupt
erst die hochleistungs stelle tritt
produziert die wir brauchen für wind
offshore wind onshore wir haben die
chemie industrie die mit leichten
materialien dafür sorgt
hochleistungsfähige windenergieanlagen
aber auch photovoltaik in deutschland zu
produzieren das ist maschinenbau und
andere dinge die wir dafür brauchen wir
brauchen aber auch in der infrastruktur
und dafür werden wir heute nachmittag
wesentliche rahmenbedingungen auf den
weg bringen zb den hochlauf der
wasserstoff-infrastruktur nicht nur
elektrolyse apparate dies wirtschaftlich
dann mit der produktion von wasserstoff
ermöglichen dass andere industrien eine
basis haben sondern auch was speicher
angeht was den ausbau der stromleitungen
angeht das ist die transformation die
wir als sozialdemokrat mit begleiten und
die hat eine basis die wirtschaft
sichert wir haben ein zweiter bereich
der digitalisierung das ist sicherlich
der ausbau der glasfaser kabel aber auch
künstliche intelligenz quantencomputer
und andere
die in der lage sein müssen die
wirtschaft zu unterstützen
bei digitalisierung haben wir aber nicht
nur wirtschaftliche voraussetzungen die
wir regeln müssen sondern wir haben auch
rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen dass es in
der gesellschaft bei digitalisierung mit
teilhabe und sozialer gerechtigkeit
dafür zusichert dass jeder an dem
technischen fortschritt auch die
möglichkeit hat teilzuhaben
der bereich fachkräfte begegnet mir
zumindest bei den besuchen in
unternehmen ist eine enorme
herausforderung die auch in dem antrag
der grünen beschrieben sind wir haben
auch einen abschlussbericht in dieser
woche vorgelegt bekommen als parlament
von der enquete-kommission berufliche
bildung da stehen viele aspekte drin die
wir berücksichtigen muss in zukunft das
geht um berufsfelder und andere digitale
dinge die einfluss haben auf die
berufliche bildung die wichtig sind um
die leistungsfähigkeit der deutschen
wirtschaft zu erhalten
und natürlich sind auch für eine
exportnation handelsverträge wichtig
dass man an fran freihandelsabkommen
gestaltet werden kann von europäischer
ebene und wir auch einbringen auf die
europäische ebene sind natürlich zugang
zu märkten aber auch mit den
nachhaltigkeits kapiteln faire
rahmenbedingungen das sind nicht nur
soziale standards das sind auch
ökologische standards aber auch
weiterentwicklung in den gesellschaften
die mit der europäischen union handel
betreiben wollen und dafür brauchen wir
eine neue offenheit dieses dieser
gestaltung hier habe ich von der grünen
fraktion so noch nicht erlebt vielleicht
wird das ja konstruktiver in der
nächsten legislaturperiode zum schluss
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren ja
sozial ökologischen wandel bis
voraussetzung ein handlungsfähiger staat
der rahmenbedingungen dafür setzen kann
aber wir brauchen auch rahmenbedingungen
die nicht nur einen immer höheren co2
preis setzen davon wird die welt eher
teurer aber nicht besser sondern wir
müssen auch staatlich flankiert
rahmenbedingungen schaffen die es
ermöglichen in der industrie diesen
wandeln diese transformation zu
organisieren nachfolgende regierungen
werden sicherlich an dem was die große
koalition begonnen hat weiterarbeiten
können die spd ist mit dem
zukunftsprogramm
staat und hat auch einen engagierten
kompetenten kanzlerkandidaten mehr wie
möglich gewesen an der einen oder
anderen stelle in der großen koalition
aber letztendlich ist das ein
erfolgreicher weg vielen dank vielen
dank herr christ ein streit
nächste reden jetzt die billige rainer
thome fdp-fraktion herr präsident meine
damen und herren 24 seiten grünen
anträge wenn man die so liest grüne
kuschel rhetorik fair gerecht nachhaltig
verbindlich aber wenn man dann mal
gucken was konkret gefordert wird dann
wird es sehr dünn und meiner meinung
nach meine damen und herren von den
grünen ist das jetzt so eine art
wahlkampf auf
sie stellen sie hier als
wirtschaftsfreundliche partei da die
offen ist für eine weltweite
kommunikation zu ab zum abschluss
verschiedenster verträge wenn man dann
aber mal ins kleingedruckte rein guckt
dann sieht man es hat sich eigentlich
gar nichts geändert und ich frage sie
zum wiederholten mal von hier aus warum
haben sie schon in den jamaika
verhandlungen ist abgelehnt dass zeta
abkommen zu ratifizieren
warum und dann habe ich mir die mühe
gemacht
in ihr wahlprogramm anzugucken und da
steht drin ein sowie zeta im moment ist
wollen wir es nicht haben auch in
zukunft nicht und selbst die dinge die
wir jetzt schon an wänden lehnen wir in
der form auch ab wir lehnen mercosur ab
wir lehnen eigentlich alle anderen
anträge entschuldigungen verträge die
geschlossen worden sind ab meine damen
und herren
doch ihr eigenes programm meine damen
und herren sie legen die latte bewusst
so hoch bei handelsverträgen dass wir
alle aufrecht stehend darunter
durchlaufen können
wer mit einem so
demokratischen land wie kanada dass uns
nun wirklich in so vielen beziehungen so
nahe steht wer mit diesem land keinen
vertrag abschließen kann nicht htc
ratifizieren will der ist nicht
regierungsfähig meine damen und herren
denn man muss mit nachbarn mit partnern
weltweit auch ein bisschen so umgehen
wie sie sind denn nicht allein am
deutschen oder gar am grünen wesen wird
die welt genesen vielen dank vielen dank
herr kollege buben
history nächster kollege pascal leyser
fraktion die linke herr präsident meine
damen und herren ob es gelingt den
wohlstand von morgen zu sichern und wenn
ja für wen ist angesichts der
bevorstehenden großen ökologischen
transformation unserer wirtschaft in der
tat eine offene frage
die beschäftigten stehen vielerorts
schon jetzt unter enormen druck zum teil
im rücken zur wand und viele von ihnen
haben den eindruck dass in der ganzen
debatte bestenfalls am rande vor
was wir dringend brauchen deshalb ein
umfassendes staatliches
investitionsprogramm und eine staatliche
aktive wirtschafts und industriepolitik
die sich an die berechtigten interessen
der beschäftigten orientiert das heißt
wir uns als linke zuallererst
beschäftigungssicherung
einkommenssicherung und eine echte
mitbestimmung der beschäftigten ja vor
den investitionsentscheidungen der
unternehmen nicht halt macht wo so meine
damen und herren das sage ich ihnen
lässt sich die akzeptanz für notwendige
klimagerechten umbau unserer wirtschaft
sicherstellen
über den wohlstand in unserem land
sprechen dann müssen wir auch festhalten
dieser wohlstand ist schon heute höchst
ungleich verteilt
das versprechen dass wer anständig und
hart arbeitet verlässlich zumindest ein
klein wenig an dem wachsenden wohlstand
teilhaben kann
dieses versprechen ist brüchen in den
ohren derjenigen die für niedriglohn
schuften und trotzdem alte auf
sozialhilfe angewiesen sind muss dieses
verspricht schon heute wie blanker hohn
klingen
insbesondere auf der anderen seite die
zahl der multi millionäre und
milliardäre beständig wächst bei den
einkommen vermögen schon lange in keinem
verhältnis mehr stehen
meine damen und herren ich sage ist
höchste zeit diese entwicklung
umzukehren und das heißt auch die
anhaltend arif luft endlich zu stoppen
denn nur darüber reden wie wir den
wohlstand für die menschen für die
mehrheit der menschen unserem land
sichern wollen dann müssen wir auch
darüber reden dass sich immer mehr
unternehmen sammeln
ihrer sozialen verantwortung entziehen
waren es vor 20 jahren noch sieben von
zehn beschäftigten der den schutz eines
tarifvertrages fehlen so ist es heute
nur noch jeder zweite
allein hat der amtszeit der aktuellen
bundesregierung hat zusätzlich über eine
million beschäftigte den schutz eines
tarifvertrages verloren ich finde es ein
unhaltbarer zustand und es ist eine
beschämende bilanz für eine regierung in
der koalitionsvertrag ist richtig heißt
tarifverträge sind ein öffentliches gut
allein im einzelhandel hat die zahl
derjenigen die in einem tarifgebundenen
betrieb arbeiten innerhalb der letzten
zehn jahre noch einmal halbiert
inzwischen ist es nicht einmal mehr
jeder dritte in dieser branche versand
und online handel sind die löhne in den
letzten zehn jahren real sogar gesunken
bei amazon kämpfen die beschäftigung zu
recht im tarifvertrag der bis heute
verwehrt wird
für den stationären tarif a1 lande wird
es immer schwieriger mit einem mit
diesem lohndumping durch den
online-handel mitzuhalten
die bundesregierung diese entwicklung
viel zu lange tatenlos zugesehen und
hier muss endlich gehandelt werden und
deswegen haben wir als linke auch hier
nochmal zum ende der legislaturperiode
sehr konkrete vorschläge vorgelegt
erster tarif muss erschwert werden
insbesondere muss unterbunden werden das
unternehmen schlupflöcher nutzen können
um sich von heute auf morgen ihrer
tarifbindung zu entledigen bis jüngst
erst beim buchhändler thalia passiert
ist zweitens die
allgemeinverbindlicherklärung von
tarifverträgen muss erleichtert werden
dazu gehört auch die
blockademöglichkeiten der
arbeitgeberverbände endlich zu streichen
meine damen und herren
und drittens öffentliche aufträge des
bundes müssen künftig an die zahlung von
tariflöhnen gekoppelt werden so wie es
die bundesländer berlin und thüringen
bereits für sich beschlossen haben und
es jetzt erfreulicherweise auch das
saarland plant
es muss endlich schluss damit sein dass
mit milliarden steuergeld lohndumping
betrieben wird meine damen und herren
aktuell sorgt diese bundesregierung
allerdings nicht einmal in ihrem
unmittelbaren verantwortungsbereich
verein ständig tariflöhne ich spreche
dass hier auch bewusst an vom bundeswehr
fuhrpark und dessen fahrerin und
die bei bedarf auch uns als abgeordnete
kreuz und quer durch berlin kutschiert
das ist die bundesregierung insbesondere
verteidigungsminister rinn kramp
karrenbauer ihnen bis heute ein
tarifwerk tag verweigert ist einfach nur
beschämend meine damen und herren zeigt
auf die unterstützung der fraktion die
linke können sie sich als fahrradfahrer
verlassen die streiken heute wieder wir
werden an ihrer seite stehen und ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn wir nicht
die einzige fraktion sie dabei
unterstützen denke das haben wir allemal
verdient meine damen und herren wer den
wohlstand von morgen sichern will der
muss hier und heute damit anfangen dass
diejenigen die hart arbeiten noch
anständig bezahlt werden die große
koalition und hier maßgeblich cdu csu
haben in den letzten jahren gezeigt dass
sie dazu nicht in der lage sind
wer allerdings glaubt mit einer schwarz
grünen bundesregierung würde dies anders
der glaubt vermutlich auch dass
zitronenfalter zitronen falten
meine damen tat ich sagen dafür braucht
es in der tat einen echten
politikwechsel
naja liegt wenn sie jetzt einen
aufschrei bei den grünen dann fühlen sie
wahrscheinlich getroffen und
wahrscheinlich zu recht
ich sage es braucht einen echten
politikwechsel in diesem land als linke
kämpfen wir weiter für einen solchen
solidarischen aufbruch und daran wird
sich zumindest bei uns auch nach der
wahl nichts ändern vielen dank
vielen dank
[Applaus]
als nächsten rennen dass ich das wort
den kollegen dr
carsten schünemann cdu herzlichen dank
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen als ich die überschrift dieses
antrages lars habe ich gedacht mensch
ich war positiv überrascht den wohlstand
von morgen sichern
fand ich gut dass die grünen jetzt auch
mal über die frage reden wo wollen wir
eigentlich in zukunft leben wollen und
nicht nur über die frage wie wir in
zukunft leben wollen die frage wovon ist
nämlich entscheidend um die frage wie zu
beantworten wenn man tiefer ein in
anderer einsteigt dann sieht man dass
sie zu 90 95 prozent des wachstums das
erreichen von neuen wachstums dem start
zuordnung des staates für wachstum
verantwortlich
weil ich zig beispiele bringen durch
regulieren durchplanen ich
subventionieren vieles mehr
da gibt es einen glasklaren die sense
und wir sagen nicht der status
verantwortlich sondern arbeitnehmer
arbeitgeber gründer erfinder die im
wettbewerb stehen der wettbewerb ist
unserer meinung nach das beste und
geeignete instrument innerhalb der
sozialen marktwirtschaft der dazu führt
dass wir die ideen haben die produkte
haben die es gibt viele kollegen haben
es gesagt wir sind deshalb so
erfolgreich werden weil es diesen
wettbewerb gibt deshalb können wir die
maschinen exportieren die anlagen
elektro und vieles mehr und das fahren
wir mit einer technologie auf diesem
feld der wollen wir uns auch bei der
klimapolitik
deswegen setzen wir uns ein für den
emissionshandel den es heute schon gibt
auf europäischer ebene für den bereich
energieintensive industrie
dort sehen wir
dass wir sehr erfolgreich co2 abbauen
weil es dort ein wettbewerb gibt ich
muss mit zertifikate kaufen das tut weh
das kostet geld
also gibt es im wettbewerb innerhalb der
wirtschaft wer am effizientesten co2
abbaut hat gewonnen und diesen
emissionshandel wollen wir gerne
ausweiten auf die bereiche verkehr und
lernen
wegen mir mit einer übergangslösung mit
einem zusätzlichen emissionshandel
erstmal wärme und verkehr um dann in
einen aufzugehen
wer blockiert das im europäischen
parlament die grünen
ich will nur mal deutlich machen wenn
wir das klimaproblem und die klimafrage
in den griff bekommen wollen
schaffen wir das mobile oder gar nicht
nur eine zahl zu nennen
in diesem jahr werden die 1,5 milliarden
tonnen co2
auf diesem globus weltweit zusätzlich
emittieren
das ist doppelt so viel wie deutschland
insgesamt in einem jahr emittiert dhs
wenn deutschland heute co2 neutral wäre
trotzdem zuwachs weltweit und 750 tonnen
co2 das ist die wahrheit und deswegen
brauchen wir eine europäische
anschlussfähigkeit möglichst in der welt
weiter anschlussfähigkeit und wir setzen
uns mit diesem emissionshandel ein das
ist klimapolitik par excellence
technologie auf dem markt schafft dann
wollen sie eine investitions und
transformation von 500 milliarden euro
in der nächsten dekade also sagen wir
mal zehn jahre pro jahr 50 milliarden
jetzt schauen wir uns mal den letzten
haushalt ab was ist da hängen geblieben
was wurde nicht abgerufen 67 milliarden
wenn ich selbst die sondereffekte aktie
durch corona wirtschaftshilfen und so
weiter komme ich auf 25 milliarden
dann habe ich noch ein sondervermögen
mit 10 milliarden wo alles das drin
steht auch was sie machen wollen
das heißt der kollege level hat doch
recht wir haben auch hier kein
geldproblem sondern ein
umsetzungsproblem wenn ihr 26 jahre
brauchen um die bahnstrecke von münchen
nach berlin auszubauen
dann haben wir doch kein geldproblem
sondern überbordet demokratie wir haben
das problem der genehmigungsverfahren wo
sie selbst den bundesrat andreas lämmel
hatten beispiele gebracht blockiert
haben wenn sie so weitermachen bei der
bahn und nicht voran kommen dann die
jetzt in den 30er jahren die flugzeuge
haben die mit wasserstoff liegen die mit
synthetischen kraftstoffen frieden die
den wettbewerb gewinnen
deswegen müssen wir jetzt bei den
genehmigungsverfahren bei vielen dingen
druck machen das dürfen sie nicht
blockieren und auch dafür steht die
union
wir wollen das nicht der staat sondern
dass der einzelne gestärkt wird
ich möchte gerne in einem land leben wo
nicht der einzelne durch neue
belastungen wahr ist bürokratie steuern
oder was auch immer konfrontiert wird
sondern mit freiräumen
ich möchte in einem land nehmen dass
wenn jemand eine idee hat einfach mal
los läuft ohne dass irgend jemand kommt
und sagt es geht nicht weil ich möchte
in einem land leben wo einst tat ab in
den ersten zwei jahren wirklich wenig
bürokratie hat damit er sich auf sein
geschäftsmodell konzentriert und nicht
auf die bürokratie
ich möchte in einem land leben ich
möchte in einem land leben und die
arbeitszeiten flexibler gestaltet werden
können als es jetzt der fall ist
und das ist sozialer mannschaft und
dafür stehen wir und dann gehen wir auch
ins amt und in dieser sozialen
marktwirtschaft und lassen sie mich das
bitte zum schluss sagen gibt es fünf
kolleginnen und kollegen von mir die
sich permanent mit voller wucht in der
ag wirtschaft dafür eingesetzt werden
das ist der kollege andreas lämmel ein
sprecher der jetzt leider aufhören das
ist der joachim pfeiffer als
langjähriger sprecher der aufhört und
das sind die kolleginnen und kollegen
astrid grotelüschen die auch da sind
peter bleser und matthias heyder
ich möchte euch danken im namen der cdu
csu bundestagsfraktion für euer
engagement nicht nur hier sondern auch
für die sache nämlich für die soziale
marktwirtschaft
wir werden das in euren sind weiter
fortführen herzlichen dank
vielen dank und es geht weiter mit timon
gremmels von der spd fraktion
[Applaus]
gut dann nehmen wir die fdp mit doktor
marke klinge ist mir auch recht
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin die
kolleginnen und kollegen die weichen für
deutschlands wirtschaftlich die zukunft
werden nach dieser pandemie neu gestellt
wir freie demokraten sind der festen
überzeugung dass wir unseren wohlstand
und unsere arbeitsplätze nur dauerhaft
erhalten können wenn wir wieder
konsequent auf wachstum marktwirtschaft
frei handeln und unternehmerinnen geist
setzen
fakt ist unsere wirtschaft hat ja schon
vor der krise erkennbar an dynamik
verloren
technologische umbrüche treffen
kernindustrien wie die automobilbranche
mit voller wucht die digitalisierung
stellt ganze wirtschaftsbereiche auf den
kopf und neue freihandelszonen in asien
verändern die gewichte in der
weltwirtschaft
der verlust an wettbewerbsfähigkeit
meine damen und herren ist aber
zuallererst ausgemacht weil diese große
koalition sich eben zu wenig um die
zukunft kümmert wo bleiben ihre großen
wirtschaftspolitischen initiativen wo
bleibt der plan für die zukunft für die
nächsten jahren zu tun gäbe es doch
genug die steuern befinden sich auf
einem rekordniveau schauen sie sich die
oecd rankings an
der staat mischt sich immer stärker in
unternehmerische entscheidungen ein
und beim zukunftsthema digitalisierung
ja da treten wir ambitionslos auf der
stelle
daher wird es jetzt zeit für eine
wirtschaftspolitische aufholjagd zeit
für eine neue wachstums und wohlstands
agenda damit deutschland auch in zukunft
ganz vorn in der weltspitze mitspielt
wie das gering
dann haben wir als fdp heute aber auch
in den vergangenen monaten hier im
deutschen bundestag immer mit immer
wieder mit einer reihe von anträgen
skizziert lassen sie mich noch einmal
drei punkte aufgreifen
erstens mehr freihandel mit klaren fokus
auf faire wettbewerbsbedingungen umwelt
und menschenrechte ist für uns eine
zentrale wachstumssäule um diese zu
stärken möchten wir zb die
welthandelsorganisation wto reformieren
und zu schnelleren vertragsabschlüssen
kommen es ist ja schon gesagt worden
zählt als auf halbem weg stehen
geblieben zweitens brauchen wir endlich
einen großen wurf beim bürokratieabbau
gerade für kleine und mittlere betriebe
für unseren mittelstand ist die
unermessliche regier regulierungswut in
deutschland mittlerweile zum zentralen
wachstumshemmnis geworden wir wollen
dafür für jede neue regel zwei
bestehende abschaffen nur so kann es am
ende funktionieren und drittens möchten
wir bei den unternehmenssteuern auf 25
prozent runter damit ja unsere firmen
und betriebe international
wettbewerbsfähig bleiben
auch das meine damen und herren ist
längst überfällig und ähnliche
entlastungsvorschläge liest mir ja
dieser woche auch im wahlprogramm von
cdu/csu nur mit dem unterschied dass die
fdp diese anträge auch ernst meint die
union verspricht in schöner
regelmäßigkeit spätestens alle vier
jahre steuererleichterungen und liefert
am ende nicht ihre glaubwürdigkeit beim
thema steuern ist mittlerweile ähnlich
hoch wie die angaben der grünen
spitzenkandidatin in ihrem lebenslauf
der kollege erlauben sie eine
zwischenfrage von herrn wollte meine
letzte rede ist wirklich drauf
verzichten vielen dank frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das große
versprechen der sozialen marktwirtschaft
laute doch jeder kann sein leben ob das
privat oder im beruflichen
wirtschaftliches aus eigener kraft
verbessern
doch immer mehr menschen zweifeln an
diesem versprechen
kein wunder haben doch so viele kleine
und mittlere unternehmen dieser pandemie
zu wenig wertschätzung und
aufmerksamkeit von uns bekommen und
deswegen möchte ich auch als sprecher
für tourismus und diese branche ist an
dem besonderen maße von corona betroffen
hier noch einmal daran erinnern dass es
gerade unseren mittelstand dass es
unsere familienbetriebe wir waren die
dieses land groß gemacht haben seien wir
also mutig spätestens nach dem 26
september und bringen wir endlich eine
neue wachstums- und aufstiegs agenda auf
diesem weg danach in die zukunft unseres
landes auch wenig gedanken
frau präsidentin für mich geht heute der
wahrscheinlich eine sehr spannende
schwierige reise zu ende
ich bin wirklich sehr stolz und dankbar
mitglied dieses wohnhauses in der 19
wahlperiode gewesen zu sein
ich möchte danke sagen in allen
insbesondere natürlich meiner fraktion
der fdp und meinen fachkolleginnen und
fachkollegen aus dem tourismus
wirtschafts und sportausschuss sowie
allen mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern
ein großes dankeschön geht natürlich
auch meine familie meine freunde und am
ein großartiges team die mich alle so
wunderbar begleitet und unterstützt
haben
ich danke dafür es war mir eine gute
ehre ich wünsche ihm alles alles gute
herzlichen dank der durch die klinge das
präsidium wünschte im namen des hohen
haus ist auch ihnen alles alles gute für
ihre berufliche weiterentwicklung
persönlich natürlich auch alles gute wir
kommen zum nächsten tag redner das ist
die man kreml ist jetzt nun mehr
fantastische fraktion sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren der himmel über dem
ruhrgebiet muss wieder blau werden
das sagte willy brandt vor genau 60
jahren
er beschrieb damit für die spd eine
nachhaltige wirtschaftsweise wie
internationale zusammenhänge und
mitdenkt den ausgleich ökologischer
ökonomischer und sozialer faktoren im
blick hat genau dieser maßstab von willy
brandt ist auch unser maßstab in dieser
koalition gewesen
wir haben oder diesen motto in den
letzten dreieinhalb jahren einiges auf
den weg gebracht
besondere erfolge sind zum beispiel das
klimaschutzgesetz was wir heute ganz in
unserem sinne noch einmal nachschärfen
werden und dann muss man aber der eher
dazu gehören hat auch etwas damit zu tun
dass wir eine sehr engagierte bewegung
auf der straße haben die da
entscheidende impulse gesetzt hat aber
auch eine umweltministerin die das zu
ihrem herzen thema gemacht hat
zweitens haben wir die co2 bepreisung
auf den weg gebracht und zwar als ein
baustein des klimaschutzes in der
energiewende und nicht den baustein
und da sagen wir ich erinnere daran weil
ich habe das gefühl dass der eine oder
andere vergisst dass er nicht nur die
große koalition allein war
nein soll die grünen haben damals im
vermittlungsausschuss des bundestages
mitgestimmt 25 euro die tonne in diesem
jahr sukzessive ansteigen bis mitte der
20er jahre
und das haben wir deswegen gemacht damit
die menschen planungssicherheit ganz im
sinne von willy brandt haben
planungssicherheit sich darauf
stellen können weil nicht jeder kauft
sich mal eben neues elektroauto sondern
die leute warten und sparen drauf sie
warten auch dass seine gebrauchtwagen
markt gibt weil die mehrheit der
menschen kaufen keine neue fahrzeuge und
genau diese zeit muss wegen geben damit
sie sich darauf einstellen können damit
sie mitmachen können damit sie dann auch
an dieser stelle entlastet werden können
und da kann man nicht mal eben sagen
weil es an gerade so passt wir machen
das jetzt alles zwei jahre schneller und
ein cent höher
die menschen brauchen da vertrauen und
planbarkeit dafür steht die
sozialdemokratie man sehr verehrten
damen und auch beim thema klima geld das
ist eine möglichkeit die haben wir auch
intensiv diskutiert aber ist ein
bürokratischer großer akt eine solches
klima geld auszuzahlen
und ehrlich gesagt so sollte man sich
mal die frage stellen auch eine pro kopf
geld das richtig ist soll denn wir als
bundestagsabgeordnete genauso viel klima
geld bekommen wie die verkäuferin bei
lidl
ich glaube das ist falsch außerdem gibt
es viel viel schneller wenn hier
wenn wir die ziele werden wir sozusagen
die einnahmen aus dem co2 preis nutzen
um die eeg umlage abzuschaffen das
entlastet die menschen spürbar schnell
ohne dass wir neue verwaltungsstrukturen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
aber ehrlich gesagt haben wir in dieser
koalition auch die richtigen maßstäbe
gesetzt wir haben gesetze wir brauchen
an dieser stelle ganz deutlich die
möglichkeit hier auch ein
konjunkturprogramm auf den weg zu
bringen dass zwei fragen gerade erledigt
und zwar die eine frage zum beispiel
cola krise überwinden und die konjunktur
anzureizen aber auch zu gucken dass all
das was wir da investieren paris
kompatibel ist genau das haben wir auf
den weg gebracht man es sehr verehrten
damen und herren und ich muss auch sagen
zum schluss vielleicht nicht ganz in
koalitionsfrieden aber die größten
bremser war unser koalitionspartner bei
all den dingen reitmeier hat eine
strompreis liege auf den weg gebracht
die strompreise diagnostiziert als
minister waren völlig jenseits der
realität hat vieles angekündigt seine
eigene fraktion ist da ganz tel
nur gefolgt ich habe mich dann auch sehr
gewundert wir haben gekämpft und die
mieter strom projekt sind die echten
schritt voran gekommen hätten uns gerne
beim mieter strom mehr gewünscht das
sage ich auch deutlich und da gucke ich
das cdu-wahlprogramm untersteht da
wirklich ein ernstes drinnen sie wollen
mieter stromprojekte erleichtert ja was
haben sie da die letzten vier jahre
gemacht wir haben ihnen da hunderte von
vorlagen gegeben und sie haben auf der
bremse steht meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren ich kann das den wählerinnen
und wählern nur sagen das ist doch
unglaubwürdig was sie da machen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren unter
größte zionismus ist dass die
mieterinnen und mieter nicht davon den
mietpreis der jetzt hier auch noch die g
co2 mehrkosten mittragen müssen dass wir
hier nicht nur ordentlich hälfte hälfte
lösung programm haben da standen sie auf
dem schlauch an ihren minister und die
bundesregierung auch im regen stehen
lassen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren frau präsidentin lassen sie mich
zum schluss sagen wir brauchen eine neue
dynamik wir brauchen klare ausbauphase
für die erneuerbaren energien für
photovoltaik auf 150 gigawatt beim wind
auf 95 gigawatt wir brauchen eine
soziale pflicht wir müssen den arten
entdecken cappella photovoltaik
abschaffen das sind die projekte wieder
mit olaf scholz sehr zügig umsetzen
werden mit einer hoffentlich koalition
die sites von cdu/csu in diesem sinne
alles gute glück auf vielen dank
erlauben sie mir den hinweis dass wir
schon weit in den morgigen tag hinein
tragen mit unserer redezeit und ich
bitte darum dass wir die redezeiten
eingehalten werden ansonsten muss ich
dann halt in das mikro abdrehen
katharina krüger bündnis 90 die grünen
das nächste gegnerin
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen es reicht nicht
klimaneutralität per gesetz
vorzuschreiben
die politik muss auch dringend etwas
dafür tun dass die ziele erreicht werden
und endlich politische entscheidungen
treffen
sehr geehrte damen und herren dieser
satz stammt nicht aus unserem antrag
obwohl daraus hätte stammen können
dieser satz stammt von siegfried
russwurm dem präsidenten des
bundesverbandes der deutschen industrie
anders des tages der industrie und der
die stimmen aus der industrie kennt und
hört der weiß dass dieses dringende
diese dringende bitte dieser appell an
sie immer verzweifelter wird das was sie
tun ist auf gegenteil von handeln das
was sie tut es doch tun ist das
gegenteil von entscheidungen treffen und
wenn man die reden von herrn löscher
trend level und lindemann in einer
reihenfolge sich den ganzen tag angehört
hat dann weiß man warum sie die
industrie mittlerweile zur verzweiflung
bringt kein satz in die zukunft kein
satz wie sie die größte herausforderung
vor der die deutschen industrie steht
adressieren stattdessen reden über
frieden freude freiheit und irgendwelche
allgemein politischen bekenntnisse kein
satz dazu handeln wäre stattdessen nötig
eine regierung die endlich ernst macht
mit dem ausbau der erneuerbaren energie
statt jahrelang nur auf der bremse zu
stehen
eine regierung die endlich mal für
vernünftige faire strompreise sorgt eine
regierung die der wirtschaft
planungssicherheit und verlässlichkeit
gibt es beim notwendigen fortschritt und
fortschritt das sind die klimaneutralen
technologien
deswegen verlangen alle von der
chemieindustrie über die stahlindustrie
sogenannte klima verträge von ihm die
die klimaneutralen technologie
wettbewerbsfähig machen und damit
deutschland international zum vorreiter
kein wort von ihnen in dieser debatte
was für ein wirtschaftspolitisches
namens zeugnis und handelspolitik
irgendwie man konnte das ja mit dem
planetarium grenzen so lustig ich sage
ihnen ganz ehrlich der verlust an
artenvielfalt den wir gerade beobachten
die immer schneller beschleunigen die
klimakrise sind nicht lustig sondern sie
sind eine überlastung unseres planeten
wo wir massiv gegensteuern müssen wo wir
mit der handelspolitik gegensteuern
müssen und auf die frage welchem
abkommen zugestimmt haben
das abkommen mit großbritannien war
einstimmig zugestimmt haben weil es eine
richtige richtung gegangen ist und ich
frage sie warum sollte etwas das mit
boris johnson möglich war
mit justins rudow nicht möglich sein es
liegt schlecht gelegen komme ich zum
schluss nie versucht hat mit kanada ein
vernünftiges handelsabkommen zu
vereinbaren
dafür braucht es politischen mut dafür
braucht es entschlossenheit dafür
braucht es auch so der profi ziele das
liefern wir mit unserem antrag und dafür
wünsche ich mir ihre zustimmung
ein bisschen
[Applaus]
es nicht es spricht für die
cdu/csu-fraktion hat los
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die gesamte
opposition sorgt sich also um den
wohlstand und die wirtschaft in unserem
land die grünen wollen den wohlstand von
morgen sichern und eine wohlstands
orientierte betrachtung als bayer sage
ich ihnen schon der vater unserer
sozialen marktwirtschaft ludwig erhard
und frau wäre möglich zu hören
er war nämlich von der union forderte
wohlstand für alle da brauchen wir keine
empfehlung aus der grünen ecke dieser
gedanke ist ab gott der union
ihr grüner wirtschaftspolitischer gleich
drei gramm lautet aber verteufeln
verteuern verbieten
sie sprechen den bürgerinnen und bürgern
das grüne vom himmel und wollen doch nur
ständig die grenzen der belastbarkeit
von menschen und wirtschaft in unserem
lande testen
sie haben nicht wohl standen sind
sondern eine fatale überlastung der
wirtschaft und der bürgerinnen und
bürger 16 cent mehr für den liter benzin
ist doch das gegenteil von wohlstand
das heißt zudem benachteiligung der
landbevölkerung und der pendler und ihr
so genanntes energie geld wir sollten
das geld von welcher stelle bekommen die
menschen spüren doch dass am ende der
normalbürger die zeche zu bezahlen hat
die grünen stehen für massive
verteuerung oder gar verbote der
kurzflüge sie wollen also dem
normalbürger auch noch den urlaub auf
mallorca verbieten dann sagen sie es
doch auch denn mit der bahn kommt man
dort nicht hin
wir von union
haben klar gemacht was wir wollen ein
programm für stabilität und erneuerung
eine gemeinsame kraftanstrengung für ein
modernes deutschland
wir wollen wohnstadt wohlstand mit
nachhaltigen wachstum zu einem
klimaneutralen industrieland deshalb
deutschland ist und bleibt ein
industrieland denn nur so sind
arbeitsplätze ist soziale sicherheit
renten und vieles mehr zu sichern
herr kollege erlauben sie eine
zwischenfrage sonst zu lang
danke wir wollen neuen mut zur
innovation aus verantwortung für die
zukunft keine grüne angst vor
technologien der zukunft
deshalb wir stehen für eine chancen
staat und nicht dem verbot statt
wir wollen beim klimaschutz ambitionen
und anderen zu verbinden sie von den
grünen wollen bevor druck bevormundung
ge und verbote deshalb kein verbot von
dieselfahrzeugen kein generelles
tempolimit kein verbot von straßenbauern
ortsumfahrungen wir wollen eine
forderung klimaneutrale mobilität
deshalb technologieoffene förderung von
elektromobilität ev lzh und wasserstoff
als antriebs technologien insbesondere
für lkw wir wollen anreize für
klimaneutrales fliegen deshalb flüge mit
alternativen kraftstoffen von der
luftverkehrssteuer befreien
mit einem ambitionierten emissionshandel
wollen wir die co2 preis um strafen und
so schnell wie möglich zu einem
europäischen emissionshandel für wärme
und verkehr übergehen einnahmen daraus
war über entlastungen beim strompreis
vollständig an bürger und unternehmen
zurückgegeben
wir wollen die abstimmung der eeg umlage
die fdp hat wiederum angst um die
deutsche exportwirtschaft und fürchtet
einen kahlschlag in automobilindustrie
ich kann sie beruhigen
wir haben die belange der deutschen
exportwirtschaft gut im blick und die
wachstumszahlen geben uns doch recht und
zeichnen den ob das optimistische bild
eines raschen wirtschaftsaufschwungs
nach der korona krise die fdp redet die
deutsche automobilindustrie schlecht die
zehn prozent zur bruttowertschöpfung
unseres landes beträgt mit mehr als
900.000 beschäftigen
sie schädigen damit aber das image der
gesamten deutschen wirtschaft
tragende säulen der des deutschen
wohlstands sind die exportwirtschaft und
die automobilindustrie
wir als union haben in unserer
wirtschafts dna fest einprogrammiert
freihandel internationales
handelsabkommen investitionen im ausland
ausländische investitionen 85 prozent
des globalen wachstums finden künftig
außerhalb der eu statt
wir als union setzen auf dem freihandel
wir setzen auf einen neuanfang mit den
usa und auf chancen für den deutschen
export in die usa
cdu/csu unterstützen das
freihandelsabkommen ca mit kanada
uneingeschränkt respektieren aber die
gegen sie laufenden verfassungsklagen
abzuwarten
im außenwirtschaftsgesetz sind erwerbs
kontrollen richtig wir stehen für einen
internationalen innovationspreis 3
zwischen den firmen auf dem weltmarkt
nicht aber für eine politik wer hat den
prallen geldbeutel im ausland bei der
automobil-industrie sprechen teile der
opposition von einer einseitigen
förderung der elektromobilität und von
politischen wunschvorstellungen die den
globalen markt nicht entsprechen würden
ich sage ihnen aber
wir stehen für technologieoffenheit und
auch für unterstützung da wo die
deutsche industrie konkret einen
offenkundigen nach nachholbedarf hatte
stichwort e mobilität der export ist für
die deutsche automobilwirtschaft eminent
wichtig globale herausforderung und
anforderungen des weltmarktes sind
entscheidend ein blick nach china aber
auch nach kalifornien zeigt es wir reden
von einem globalen trend
allein in china gab es 2009 10 rund 500
hersteller von e fahrzeugen und tesla
ist mittlerweile aus den usa ein begriff
für jedermann in diesem land daher
müssen wir die politik beim
technologiewandel die industrie
unterstützen
das hat nichts mit politischen und
vorstellungen zu tun
im konjunkturprogramm ist unter ziffer
35 c bereits ein förderprogramm für
zukunftsinvestitionen der
fahrzeughersteller und der
zulieferindustrie im gesamtvolumen von 2
milliarden euro aufgelegt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
opposition
veränderungen sind chancen keine
bedrohungen optimismus statt pessimismus
sie reden wir handeln vielen dank für
die aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank
als nächstes das wort der fraktionslose
kollege marco bülow
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin wir damen
und herren ihre kolleginnen kollegen
ich danke für diesen antrag der grünen
wohlstand von morgen sichern
ich stelle mich mal ein bisschen an den
begriff transformation ich hätte gerne
einen einfachen also den umbau der
gesellschaft weil es eigentlich auch
noch ein bisschen weiter geht den wir
brauchen und zwar genau sozial und
ökologisch und da fangen die eigentlich
auch an über diese legislatur zu
sprechen
die große koalition hat er versucht es
soziale wird der ökologischen im auge
einander auszuspielen genau damit kommen
wir natürlich nicht zu den wohlstand von
morgen das zweite ist wir dürfen eben
nicht immer nur über die vergangenheit
reden in diesem wirtschaftssystem
sondern mehr über die zukunft da nehme
ich mal ein beispiel ist kann nicht sein
dass auf der einen seite sehr stark über
die autoindustrie geredet wird ja mit
vielen arbeitsplätzen auf der anderen
seite aber die arbeitsplätze die sie
kaputt gemacht haben bei den
erneuerbaren branche nur über 100.000
plätze arbeitsschritte kaputtgegangen
keine rede wert sind sondern im
gegenteil abstandsregelungen geschaffen
worden sind bei windkraft des sonate
geschaffen worden die arbeitsplätze
zerstört haben diese arbeitsplätze
scheinbar haben die große koalition
nicht interessiert vor allen dingen
nicht die union
von daher glaube ich müssen wir da
anfangen möchte aber auch ein beispiel
noch mal deutlich machen und einen
vorschlag machen weil wir glaube ich
immer stark auf wohlstand definieren mit
mit mit kosten und wohlstand definieren
mit klaren zahlen wir müssen aber glaube
ich nicht nur noch die momentaufnahme
schauen
das finde ich zum beispiel bei der
pandemie den eigentliche folgen gerade
auch das lockt downs in der pandemie
werden uns erst betreffen und ich meine
jetzt nicht nur gesundheitlich sondern
ich meine vor allem psychische soziale
und wirtschaftliche folgen und die
müssen zusammengedacht werden wir dürfen
nicht in neun sparten und den
spezifischen themen denken
deswegen schlage ich vor dass wir einen
sonderausschuss in den neuen bundestag
gründen natürlich parteiübergreifend
fraktions übergangen ist es ja klar aber
auch themenübergreifend mit experten
experten die alle themen auf der
tagesordnung bringen damit wir unseren
wohlstand sichern können ich will nur
ein beispiel ein aspekt nämlich genau
immer unter geht es gab jetzt eine
studie die besagt dass die bildung in
dem jahr sind die schulen das team das
die schülerinnen und schüler so viel
gelernt haben zu hause ungefähr so wie
als wenn sie ferien gehabt hätten
das wird uns auf die füße fallen
deswegen müssen wir dieses bildungsthema
auch damit reinbringen und deswegen
brauchen wir diese aspekte zusammen
gedacht und diesem sonderausschuss und
dann kommen wir zu dem wohlstand für
alle also in der wohlstand für alle für
die union bedeutet dass drei familien in
diesem land so viel besitzen die 50
prozent der bevölkerung dann sprechen
wir nicht nur wohlstand für alle sondern
wohlstand für einige wenige das ist
genau das modell was ich nicht haben
möchte und was wir überwinden müssen
wohlstand für alle heißt auch alle zu
beteiligen
von daher glaube ich sollten wir sehen
wirklich mal eine zusammenarbeit zu
haben übergreifend über die themen und
die sachen wirklich zusammen zu bringen
ich weiß sie werden diesen
sonderausschuss nicht einrichten aber
wenn die partei die partei mit über 50%
einzieht dann können sie nicht um ruhm
dass dieser ausschuss dann doch
eingerichtet wird aber ich lade sie dazu
alle herzlich ein
vielen dank danke
als letzten redner in der debatte und
der johann saathoff von der spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ja die grünen
legen mit dem antrag heute ein kleines
wahlprogramm auf den tisch und zentral
für den wohlstand von morgen ist ganz
sicher die klima- und energiepolitik
klima und energiepolitik die untrennbar
verbunden ist unser kanzlerkandidat olaf
scholz das ja auch gesagt wird der
industrie politik und dann macht es aus
meiner sicht auch sinn heute mal ein
bisschen bilanz zu ziehen
die union hat aus meiner sicht in den
vergangenen vier jahren ihre allergie
gegen die erneuerbaren ausreichend
gepflegt immer wieder gab es neue
vorwände in der großen in der großen
koalition gegen den verstärkten ausbau
von erneuerbaren energien die akzeptanz
wurde vorgeschoben
es gab eine koalitionsinterne
arbeitsgruppe die mehr als ein jahr lang
getagt hat die cdu wollte über
abstandsregeln windkraftausbau zum
erliegen bringen wir sozialdemokraten
konnten das vermeiden
weitere vorwand war die dispatch kosten
also die kosten die entstehen wenn
erneuerbare wegen netzengpässen
abgeschaltet werden müssen die antwort
darauf gibt es auch die liegt im
stromnetz und es gibt gute ansätze im
wirtschaftsministerium zur
digitalisierung von stromnetzen zu
reaktiven betriebsführung all das ist
leider im sand verlaufen
ob mieter strom ob sonder ausschreibung
wir mussten alles harte kämpfen selbst
jetzt noch mit klimaschutzgesetz und
cdu-wahlprogramm weigert sich die union
ausbau mengen der erneuerbaren energie
bis 20 30 zu erhöhen sie hätten jetzt
noch die zeit die nächsten stunden
klar ist für eine politik mit echten
klimaschutz braucht es eine regierung
ohne cdu und es braucht die spd
die initiative zur deckelung und
mittelfristigen abschaffung der
eeg-umlage kam von der spd
wir haben das klimaschutzgesetz gemacht
wir haben den kohle ausstieg beschlossen
wir haben den ausgleich zwischen
klimaschützern und kohle kumpeln
geschafft wir haben die nationale co2
bepreisung eingeführt und gleichzeitig
auch die carbon leakage verordnung für
die industrie wir scheuen uns nicht vor
der diskussion der fechten sie auf und
wir treffen entscheidungen nicht wie
erhalten meyer der bei dem zugegebenen
komplizierten aber wichtigen thema der
spitzen kaputt sein ein sein entwurf
einfach wieder in der schublade
verschwinden lässt wenn die
automobilindustrie mal leicht hüstelt
wir wollen mehr staatlichen einfluss bei
den stromnetzen die entscheidung von
schwarz-gelb zum verkauf der stromnetze
war und ist ein schwerer fehler der uns
heute immer noch anlastet ebenso der
ausstieg aus dem atomausstieg dank ihnen
zahlen wir den konzernen 2,4 milliarden
euro liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
cdu csu und der fdp und er ist gestern
wurde im wirtschaftsausschuss wieder
deutlich dass in den reihen der union
immer noch einige meckern dass wir uns
von der atomenergie verabschieden
ich war vor zwei wochen in tschernobyl
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und finde
das müsste eigentlich zum
pflichtprogramm eines jeden
energiepolitik aus dieser erde werden
und nun zum antrag der grünen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich sehe naturgemäß auch über die
letzten jahre schon viele schnittmengen
allerdings fehlt die sozial gerechte
verteilung der lasten aus meiner sicht
ein energie geld sofern es sich
überhaupt technisch irgendwie
bewerkstelligen lässt ist genau so
sozial wie eine kopfpauschale bei der
krankenversicherung
da bekommt da bekommt er
genauso viel wie die kassiererin und
gleich ist eben nicht automatisch auch
gerecht außerdem ist es eine
umverteilung von den ländlichen räumen
die städte das wollen wir nicht
starke schultern müssten auch mehr last
tagen deswegen braucht es die spd
gleiches gilt für ihre vorstellung bei
der co2 bepreisung mit 60 euro treffen
sie einige menschen sehr schnell sehr
hart denken sie mal an die menschen im
ländlichen raum die in alten gebäuden
leben und weite wege zur arbeit haben
diese müssen wir mitnehmen ihre
akzeptanz zu klima zum zur
energiepolitik brauchen wir den grünen
klimaschutz muss man sich leisten können
den sozialen ausgleich gibt es nur mit
der spd
sie müssen sich entscheiden zwischen
energie geld und abschaffung der
eeg-umlage und sie müssen auch eine
entscheidung treffen zwischen
klimaschutz datenschutz
man kann die man aus friesland sagt man
kann nicht zwei peer mit 1 8 ist eben
riesen herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank ich schließe die aussprache
wir kommen zur abstimmung über den
antrag der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen auch drucksache 30 882 mit dem
titel die ökologisch soziale
transformation der handelspolitik zum
schutz von klima umwelt und
menschenrechten
wer stimmt für diesen antrag fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen wir stimmen
dagegen von spd cdu/csu fdp und afd wer
enthält sich dessen die fraktion die
linke der eintrag gesamt abgelehnt
tagesordnungspunkt 11 a
wir kommen zur abstimmung über den
antrag der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen auf drucksache 30 952 mit dem
titel den wohlstand von morgen sichern
wer stimmt für diesen antrag fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen bestimmt dagegen
spd cdu csu fdp und fdp enthält sich
fraktion die linke
der antrag ist damit abgelehnt